good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight Elon Musk became famous
as a businessman he makes electric cars
and Rockets and has become the single
richest person on planet Earth by doing
that Elon Musk is not from the United
States he grew up in South Africa and
yet he has a keen and precise
understanding of how our system was
designed to work as he put it on Twitter
last month quote free speech is
essential to a functioning democracy
and then musk asked his 80 million
followers on Twitter a very simple
question quote do you believe Twitter
rigorously adheres to that principle and
overwhelmingly they answered no it
doesn't so Elon Musk understands
something about Twitter that many people
in our country don't understand which is
it is the single most important forum
for speech possibly in the world not
because it's the biggest but because
it's where Elite opinion is incubated
and so free speech on Twitter matters
and last month Elon Musk gave the
impression that he planned to do
something about it that he planned to
open up Twitter he bought 10 of the
company
now today musk has just put in an offer
to buy 100 of Twitter at 54 dollars a
share and take the company private now
from a business perspective this is a
very tempting offer for the company in
fact his offer represents a 54 premium
over the company's share price the day
before he began investing in it
he wrote a letter to Twitter's board
last night quote Twitter has
extraordinary potential he wrote I will
unlock it
so this is more than a business plan
fact it's not an overstatement to say it
could be the single most important
development for free speech in the
modern history of the United States
as musk put it Twitter's potential is to
be quote the platform for free speech
around the globe
Twitter will quote neither Thrive nor
serve the societal imperative in its
current form Twitter needs to be
transformed as a private company
musk then made it clear that he has no
confidence whatsoever the people who
currently run Twitter including its
pro-censorship CEO quote if this deal
doesn't work given that I have no
confidence in management nor do I
believe I can drive the necessary change
in the public market I would need to
reconsider my position as a shareholder
that means if Twitter's board rejects
Elon musk's offer they will need to
explain why to their shareholders they
turn down a deal that would make the
shareholders much richer
so by doing this Elon Musk is putting
everything on the line he knows how
important Twitter is to the people who
run our system and run the global system
for them censorship and propaganda are
not a feature of their rule their rule
depends on censorship and propaganda if
you are offering policies that really
benefit nobody but yourself you have to
lie about them and you must prevent
anyone from complaining about it so
censorship and propaganda are at the
very heart of neoliberalism
and Elon Musk is challenging all of that
directly
he's the richest man in the world he's
not trying to make more money he's not
donating to a foreign charity or
creating a tax shelter for himself at
least in this case he's using his money
to allow at least potentially Americans
to speak freely
is it distressing that our own
democratic system isn't working that you
would need some rich guy to swoop in
deus ex machina to save free speech in
the United States of course it is is it
sad that we're all desperate for Elon
Musk to save us yes it is but who else
is going to save us nobody at this point
so of course corporate media which
exists to stifle the views of individual
Americans hates the idea and their first
move is to mock it watch
he says he wants to pay 54.20 a share to
buy up the rest of Twitter that he
doesn't have of course 54.20 that's 420
that's a code for marijuana you know
which he very much enjoys so is this all
a troll or is this very real she's so
bizarre right I mean the 420 Cody and
everything is it just a troll right
because if he's not going to negotiate
he says this is this is my best and
final last and final offer I'm not going
to negotiate here is this just some sort
of game is he doing it for the laws
it can't really be real
well think it through for a second by
challenging the Monopoly on speech not
just the United States but globally on
Twitter on this Central platform for
ideas Elon Musk is risking everything
that he has he's many businesses
intersect with governments around the
world they're not for this they could
crush him for even suggesting it so he's
all in he has to be all in even to say
something like this
at Twitter they know he's all in and
that's why they're so upset about it
according to a Bloomberg before reporter
even before musk's offer today of a
hostile takeover quote the vibe among
workers at Twitter is quote super
stressed with employees quote working
together to help each other get through
the week
that's how threatening this is and you
have to ask yourself what kind of
company is Twitter
the company's stock just jumped 30
percent that happened when Elon Musk
first bought in
so obviously this is not a company that
exists to make money this is a company
that exists to censor speech that's its
whole purpose
the bite Administration certainly
understands this and they've already
made a move to intimidate musk into
backing off
Fox business's Charlie gasparin was
reporting tonight the quote as Elon Musk
offers to buy the rest of Twitter a
legal Source tells Fox Business that the
SEC and the doj have launched what he
described as a joint investigation into
a myriad of musk regulatory issues
primarily involving Tesla
in other words threaten to allow people
to speak freely and will crush your
businesses
that's third world Behavior at the
Washington Post owned by also one of the
richest people in the world Max boot
very much supports stopping Elon Musk
in fact Elon musky tells us must be
silenced in the name of democracy quote
I am frightened by the impact on society
and politics of Elon Musk acquires
Twitter he seems to believe that on
social media anything goes for democracy
to survive we need more content
moderation not less
really
so for democracy to survive the citizens
in the Democracy need to talk less need
to express their opinions more guardedly
need to shut up what kind of democracy
are we talking about
it's not democracy as the Athenians or
the founders of this country understood
that democracy is a euphemism for
letting our Mafia run your country for
our benefit
uh journalism Professor called Jeff
Jarvis explained today on Twitter that
tyranny is when the regime can't censor
its own citizens quote today on Twitter
feels like the last evening in a Berlin
Nightclub at the Twilight of the Weimar
Germany in other words you're a Nazi if
you're for speaking freely on Twitter
CNBC host Joe Kernan understands exactly
what's going on if Twitter is opened up
that means people who are paid to censor
the public on Twitter will lose their
ability they'll lose their guardianship
of free speech watch this
who's that ADL guy Andrew this is his
worst nightmare I think Jonathan uh
Greenblatt it's going to be you're on
the Green Bay I mean if he owns the
whole place it's going to be like go for
it I think it's going to be and and the
orange man probably going to be back and
I uh this is unbelievable
he's exactly right again you can't
overstate what a threat this is not
simply to the people occupying seats of
political power but to the whole
non-profit universe that exists and
thrives and becomes rich supporting them
through censorship and propaganda so a
group like the ADL or Media Matters take
money in order to censor people they
issue some report calling you a racist
and then social media shuts you down
Elon Musk is saying no people should be
able to speak freely that would mean the
end of their control over speech groups
like The ADL and Media Matters
so the media and these non-profit groups
have to stop this before it happens
here's MSNBC telling you that Elon Musk
must be stopped because he's a bigot
he's one of the most thin-skinned people
on social media and this week he tried
to come for Senator Elizabeth Warren who
tweeted let's change the rig tax code so
that the person of the year will
actually pay taxes and stop freeloading
off everyone else
well Elon wasn't happy so he did what he
always did and stomped his little feet
and insulted Senator Warren calling her
an angry mom and referring to her as
Senator Karen
so for so many reasons being a
freeloader and a selfish and
disrespectful one and for
misappropriating black vernacular from
misogynistic purposes Elon Musk is the
absolute worst
so all of a sudden the political party
that's supported almost exclusively by
oligarchs like Jeff Bezos and the Google
guys is telling you that it's dangerous
for rich people to have too much control
over speech really
Facebook is controlled by one person
Mark Zuckerberg but that's not a threat
because Mark Zuckerberg is happy to work
on behalf of the democratic party once
again if anything we are understating
what a big deal this move on Twitter by
Elon Musk is if free speech is restored
to even one big social media platform it
all comes tumbling down subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube channel to catch our
nightly opens stories that are changing
the world and changing your life from
Tucker Carlson tonight